[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
about 30 miles off the coast of brazil
just south of sap hollow brazil
is an island called kimana grande
better known as snake island the
beautiful island is
untouched by human developers for a good
reason
brazil has made it illegal for anyone to
visit because it's
just too dangerous researchers estimate
that on the 106 acre island live between
two and four thousand snakes the snakes
survive by feeding on the many migratory
seabirds that use the island as a
resting point
among the many snakes that infest the
island is the deadliest which is the
golden land's head
a pit viper that is responsible for 90
percent of brazilian snakebite
fatalities
the golden lance heads possess a
powerful fast-acting venom
that melts the flesh around their bites
marcelo duarte
a biologist who's visited snake island
over 20 times
he said the island has about one snake
per square
yard this means you're never more than
three feet away from death
did you know the bible talks about
another serpent that is much more deadly
than the golden lance head stay with us
friends we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
hello listening friends and we're glad
that you've tuned in for bible answers
live
and we do have phone lines open if you'd
like to call in with your bible question
that's why we're here it is a live
international interactive bible study
and we'd love to have you participate by
listening
by calling in with a question and you
can even pray for us as we do our best
to search the word of god for
truth-filled answers the number for the
studio is
god 800-463-7297 800-463-7297 you can
call with your questions now
good chance you'll get your call on
tonight's program we're also streaming
this
if you've got a facebook account you can
go to the doug batchelor facebook
page or the amazing facts facebook page
that's amazing facts ministries or
amazing facts international
and you can watch what's going on as
well as listen
and my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross good evening friends and
pastor doug as we always do let's start
the program with prayer
dear father we thank you that we're able
to take this time to open up your word
and study together
the most important way of spending time
is
in your word and so we do ask you a
blessing be with those who are listening
lord guide us here in the studio before
we ask us in jesus name
amen amen pastor you opened the program
by talking about well one of the least
uh favorite my least favorite animal
without a doubt
and that is a snake i don't like snakes
as you know
growing up in africa uh there's not too
many
friendly snakes the snakes there are
very deadly
but here is an entire island just
infested with snakes it seems as though
i actually saw a little documentary on
uh this island and
wherever you look it looks as though the
the trees are living
because they're moving with these snakes
everywhere and
just probably somebody's worth worse
nightmare is to wake up on the island
my mother was like that she was for
whatever reason she would
scream if she saw snake on television
and my brother and i used to torment her
we'd take the rubber snakes and stick
them in her
drawers and things but uh yeah you know
that
this snake um the golden landsat is
a a very deadly snake and
i've killed several rattlesnakes and in
my youth i
i even ate a couple when i lived up in
the hills and i don't recommend it but
um yeah this snake though
you most people don't die from
rattlesnake bites you can usually get to
help you can get seriously injured
but this snake it it can have a high
mortality rate
and it makes me think of the most deadly
snake in the world is actually found in
the bible
and you can read about this in
revelation chapter 12
and it talks about the dragon that old
serpent called the devil and satan
who is cast out of heaven and it says he
deceives the whole world
and you find that in revelation 12 verse
9 so that great dragon was cast out that
serpent of old
the reason of course it calls it a
serpent is it go back to the garden of
eden
and the first time the devil sort of
manifested his
evilness towards the human race was
through
possessing a serpent as the medium and
he deceived
eve and adam and through the bible
several times it talks about
through the power of god it says you
will trample the serpent
and the scorpion and there's even a
place where it says you will take up the
serpent and now we're not supposed to go
out
pick up snakes but it means we'll be
able to do battle with the devil
through the power of christ and uh
yeah there's the venom of the devil has
taken out so many in the world
and it reminds us of where jesus said in
john chapter 3 verse 15 now almost
everyone knows john 3 16.
but in john 3 15 jesus said as moses
lifted up the serpent in the wilderness
even so must the son of man be lifted up
that whosoever believes
in him might not perish but have
everlasting life
and christ is referring back to that
story from the book of numbers where
the people were bitten by a plague of
fiery serpents
and they were they're all dying from
this venom
and moses was instructed to make a
bronze serpent and put it on the pole
shepherd's staff and lift it up and
whoever would look
would live and for the shepherds that
serpent on a pole represented a defeated
serpent because they used to kill snakes
and they carried off with
their staff and christ said when he was
lifted up on the cross
he provided the cure for the venom
the anti-venom is the blood of jesus for
the curse of sin and that's available to
everyone that asks and some might be
wondering pastor ross if god's a loving
god then
why did he make a devil and we have a
study guide that deals with that
uh it's called did god create the devil
and um it answers the question if god is
good why are there so many bad things
in our world why is this sin and
suffering and death
we'd encourage you to uh call and we'll
be happy to give you the study guide for
free it's part of the amazing fact set
of study guides
it's called did god create a devil the
number to call for that is 800-835-6747
that is that resource
phone line asked the study guide did god
create a devil
and we will get that in the mail and
send it to you if you're in north
america
we'll send it to you in the mail if
you're outside of north america
we want to encourage you to go to the
amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.com
you'll be able to read that study guide
there at the website as well
well we're going to go to the phone
lines our first caller is
calling gladys is calling from the
philippines gladys welcome to the
program
hi pastor ross hi pastor doug hi gladys
how are you doing
i'm fine thank you so much but before i
give my question
i just wanted to be amazing facts
uh with your ministry especially the
online um articles that you're giving
because because of that i was able to
reach
my community especially the young ones
regarding the word of god so thank you
so much
absolutely praise the lord and your
question so um here's my question
yes um i joined an online bible seminar
last night and the topic was all about
where the sin started and the speaker
came to a question regarding asked
why satan was cast out here on earth
rather than
on other unfollowing worlds
that he created but um that god created
but
um the speaker wasn't able to um answer
that question
so i'm curious if the bible has an
answer on this question
all right thank you good question so
when satan was cast out why did god cast
the devil to the earth why did he pick
us
and why did the devil come down here as
opposed to other maybe unfallen worlds
well
during the rebellion in heaven evidently
the devil was
trying to recruit anybody to join him he
did
succeed in joining in recruiting
one-third of the other angels
and joining him in his rebellion and it
tells about that in revelation 12 also
his tale drew i think it's in revelation
12 a third of the stars of heaven
and did cast them to the earth uh but
here on this planet was the first place
the devil actually
found a world that was willing to listen
to his suggestions and sin against god
and join him in his rebellion
and in romans chapter 6 it tells us
whoever you obey that's whose servants
you are
now god originally gave adam and eve
dominion of the world
but when adam and eve chose to obey the
laws of the devil
and the word of the devil instead of the
word of god they surrendered that
dominion
and satan then had the right to
basically to kidnap this planet
because they had given them that opening
so that's why
it's not that god just arbitrarily said
i think i'll send him down to torment
the earth satan probably was trying to
tempt other worlds but this is the first
one where he found a foothold
you know we've got a dvd it's called
cosmic conflict that talks about this
and
it's free you can just watch it i
believe on youtube if you type in
amazing facts cosmic conflict you'll be
able to see that
documentary that we have talking about
the subject of
the fall of lucifer and uh the
temptation here on the earth
and i think gladys you'll enjoy that
just go and take a look at that at
youtube
thank you thanks for your call we've got
ron listening right here in roosevelt
ron welcome to the program thank you for
me hey pastor doug that's ross hi ron so
so i'm going through exodus i'm reading
the uh you know about the 40 years in
the desert
and i'm fascinated about when i get to
the park of the tabernacle and the
instructions that
god gave to moses to build a tabernacle
and specifically in
exodus 38 24 he goes into how much gold
and silver and the talons that took
place to build that
and i'm fascinated how much gold and
silver i mean when i add up the weights
here and how much they use it looks like
a hundred thousand pounds of silver a
couple of tons of gold
and that's just for the gold and silver
part and not for all the the pipes and
the wood and the materials used for
thing i know how long it takes to break
down a circus tent and with that they
use
cranes and and trucks to tow all that
stuff how do they
move this massive thing across the
desert for 40 years and have the
the power to do that okay great question
and i when i first read this i wondered
the same thing and you look at that well
first of all we know they had no problem
carrying the gold because
when they built the sanctuary they're
already deep in the wilderness so
they spoiled the egyptians and it tells
us that and i forget what pastor what
passage did his pastor ross what it says
they spoiled the egyptians
who gave them articles of gold and
silver and jewels
but um for all the years they had worked
for free finally they told the egyptians
you got to pay us and the egyptians were
happy to get rid of the israelites
after all the plagues and they just they
basically just
laid in them with gold and jewels and
purges exodus chapter 3 verse 22
says that they receive gold and clothing
and
articles of silver from the egyptians so
now they're down at mount sinai when
they build the sanctuary so they've
already you know they're carrying it but
it's in small pieces
but when they build the sanctuary i
think the sanctuary is only all together
it's like 150 feet including the
courtyard so it's not as big as like a
circus tent but it is
it is big but you've got almost
well they had like 600 000 soldiers
so you look at the number of people they
had
and they had and then the camels you
know i've heard a camel can carry six to
eight hundred pounds depends on the
type and size of the camel uh those
camels were carrying
a lot and the whole sanctuary was made
in
segments and well like you can read here
it says 100 sockets i'm in verse 27
100 sockets from the 100 talents from
each socket and so they've got these
sockets that the boards
go into and it assembles like a big lego
project and whenever they moved and they
didn't move every day
you know over a period of 40 years some
places they stayed for a couple years i
think
and so they'd set it up and yeah they
would they'd break it all down
and just like you mentioned a a circus
train they used to take all the circus
uh
implements and they loaded on different
train cars and they'd go through
the midwest to the next location well
these folks use camels instead of
certain
trains and they'd put it all back
together again
and of course there was a whole tribe
dedicated to the service of the
sanctuary
so they had to put it together take it
apart and carry it and
it was quite the operation and then also
you know we got to remember that
when the israelites moved from one place
to another and of course they were
guided by the cloud
and the pillar of fire by night um there
were children women
old folks young folks so they didn't
move very quickly
so they'd probably walk a little ways
and stop and raise they had all the
flocks
yes all the animals it was it was a big
operation to move
yeah well good question ron we thank you
now we have a
lesson don't we pass ross on the
sanctuary yes it's called uh
god drew the plans and it's about the
sanctuary and we'll be happy to send
this to
anyone who calls and asks god drew the
plans the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four
seven just ask for the study guide god
drew the plans
uh next quarter that we have is george
listening in new jersey george welcome
to the program
uh good evening pastors how you doing
tonight good thank you for calling
yes uh recently first of all for the
question i just got uh one of your
pamphlets in the mail america in bible
prophecy i didn't
request it but i certainly appreciate
i'm enjoying looking at it and
reading about it bless your heart no
it's a gift thank you we're glad you're
enjoying it
okay thank you uh a question i have
tonight not any particular scripture but
is it important to know the exact day
that you
became a christian over the years
sometimes people say why did you become
a christian and
i don't actually remember because when
you grow up in the church sometimes you
don't remember those
those incidents you know what i'm saying
so um i know
i know i was a teenager but i know
several times
after being a teenager i asked the lord
to come into my heart so i'm not really
sure if
that was the time or was several years
later or
or what sometimes it does bother me a
little bit so just want to get your
input on that
yeah though that's great you know some
some people have a dramatic
experience like paul where he knows the
day he got struck
by the light of the lord and they call
that a damascus road experience
and then you've got people where
conversion is sort of a series of steps
and
and they kind of they grow more like a
plant and next thing you know that
they're out of the ground they can't
really pick the day when it happened
i'm like that you know i know for me
going from
being an atheist to an agnostic to a
christian
was a process and at some point i did
get down
and i prayed and asked god into my heart
i regret now i don't know what that day
was it didn't matter to me
what the date was and i was living in a
cave i don't even know if i knew what
the days of the week were at that time
but i've always thought well i don't
know what that date was i do know the
date when i got baptized because i've
got a certificate for that
and so that's you know an important date
but now have you been baptized
when i was a teenager uh by immersion in
the church that i go to yes
yeah so you probably have that date and
so you can look back
but yeah i don't think it's necessary to
say i can point to the exact time
at some point i'm sure you prayed and
and you said you prayed several times
and said lord you know take my life and
yeah i don't
i don't see anywhere in the bible where
it says you have to be able to pick the
day that
uh it all happened even with the
disciples of jesus
you know they're following christ then
they're arguing with each other and then
they follow him again
then they you know they deny him and
then
they repent and then he fills him with
the holy spirit
and then a few years later peter starts
getting distracted with
uh you know the trying to please the
jews and paul has to
chastise him and so it was even a little
bit of a process for the apostles of
growing
um so not everybody can point to the day
you know there is a verse i can share
with you
and that would be in john chapter 3
verse 7
christ said don't marvel that i say to
you you must be born again
and then verse 8 the wind blows where it
wishes and you hear the sound of it but
you cannot
tell where it comes from and where it
goes
so is everyone who is born of the spirit
sometimes you may not be able to put
your finger on the place but
that doesn't mean you're any less
converted george and i hope that will
encourage you
thank you for your question next caller
that we have is jerry listening in texas
jerry welcome to the program
hey fantastic guys thanks for taking my
call
yes sir my question is uh
refers to i think it's second kings 316.
i might have to check back my notebook
on that but can we
consider that when solomon
slew abner his
cousin i guess can we assume that abner
he had you know he'd been a servant of
god had been a
very good soldier but he had followed
king david's rules rather than
some of god's uh rules
can we assume that when abner
clung to the horns of the altar do you
mean
abner after jesus you mean abner you
mean joab
yeah i'm sorry joab killed abner you're
right yeah
can we assume that uh when joab
clung to the altar as solomon had his
guards
kill him can we assume that he was
clinging to the cross of calvary in the
great mercies of
god our creator you know my personal
opinion on this of course no one can
really judge if someone was saved or not
but i've
i've preached some sermons on joab and
the fact that he went to the lord
joab was guilty of killing uh
a uh ahab not ahab abner
and but it wasn't you know
it was a little treacherous what he did
but he had killed his
brother and back then they had some laws
about blood feud
and so you know what he did was wrong
david even said he took innocent blood
joab killed
a massa and he killed abner
but you know he sounds like he repented
and he went
and he was clinging to the altar and
bannonis had come away from the altar
and he said
no slay me here and ben and i went back
to solomon said what am i supposed to do
and solomon said well he may repent and
god may forgive him
i'm paraphrasing now but he said he's
guilty of innocent blood
he needs to pay the penalty so he was
killed and i think there's a verse
pastor ross
that where it says in exodus it talks
about that yeah exodus chapter 21 verse
14.
it says but if a man acts with
premeditated against his neighbor to
kill him
by treachery you shall take him from my
altar that he might die
so almost in anticipation of somebody
fleeing into the temple
yeah the word of the lord says if they
guilty of murder
and premeditated with joab it was
premeditated even though he probably
thought it was vengeance but
and you know i think also joab you read
a little earlier in the story he kind of
sided with
the wrong side out of niger yeah and um
that was a bit of a threat
to solomon and his rule so there was an
issue there as well
all right hey great thanks so much for
your question thank you for your
congestion
gentlemen god bless you and your
ministry appreciate amen
bye-bye thank you next caller that we
have is mike
in missouri st louis missouri mike
welcome to the program
how are you guys doing tonight we're
having a great time
how are you doing i'm having a great
time too
um my my thing is uh
my question is in reference to the story
of the rich man
yeah that asks jesus how he can have
eternal life
and of course jesus quotes the last six
commandments
but here's my question it's about where
in matthew chapter 19 verse 20
the rich man says he kept those
commandments
and my question is is the rich man
asking how he can have a better
resurrection
and my reference to that is hebrews
chapter 11
verse 35 okay
yeah and i know the verse you're talking
about in hebrews let's go before we go
there let's go to
the rich man this rich young ruler when
jesus
he says you know what must i do to have
eternal life christ says keep the
commandments he says which ones
and he begins to recite the commandments
on the second table
meaning the ones that deal with man and
his fellow man
and every jew knew all those by heart
and so the young man says all these i've
kept i've known them from my youth
what do i lack well jesus was getting to
the heart of it it wasn't just his
actions it was his attitude
he really didn't love his fellow man
christ said look you're a very rich man
because you've been hoarding your wealth
and if you want to follow me
you need to unload go sell what you have
give it to the poor
you'll have treasure in heaven and so
jesus is talking he said you know you're
really attached to your treasure
and uh he went away sad he couldn't do
that christ was even asking him to be
a disciple really an apostle he said
follow me just like he said to peter and
john
follow me and he he couldn't do it
and he even says in this story christ
looking at him loved him i think that's
in the
mark's version he had great potential so
he was maybe keeping the letter of the
law but not the spirit of the law
and so i don't think in hebrews when
he's talking about those who want to
obtain a better resurrection
was referring to people like the rich
young ruler there's no record
the rich young ruler went away sad
because he had great possessions no
record
that he may have changed his mind or
what happened there's
there's a few traditions but we don't
know but uh christ was letting us know
it's so hard for a rich man to enter the
kingdom
because they trust in their riches
all right so uh yeah i hope that helps
does that answer your question
well i i've been so in other words but
the rich man
was saved though right i mean because
he just he just couldn't he couldn't go
he couldn't attain perfection
you know it's hard to judge whether he's
saved or not it just it doesn't look
good on the surface because
jesus tells him what to do and he said
he went away grief or he had great
possessions
it's like he walked away from christ and
it says that you know he just said oh
man that's too much
uh if he had like zacchaeus came to
jesus he said half my goods i give to
the poor and he rejoiced
this man walks away from christ he
doesn't follow him as jesus said follow
me
he didn't follow him he walked away i
think that
it doesn't look good for him right now
from just the bible record
so but hey we thank you so much for that
that's a good question
the next caller that we have is uh
josiah listening in
washington josiah welcome to the program
thank you uh pastor doug and pastor ross
been listening
um from a child and really appreciate
the time that you take for this well
thank you
get real close to your phone you sound
like you're kind of echoing in the
distance
my apologies that's the thing uh uh is
that better much better
i i'm sorry probably thought the first
time i'd be on the radio
would remember to take my phone off
speaker phone but that's okay
and your question well
it's uh one about fear pretty much
um i get fearful sometimes
that the enemy is like uh
you know spiritually we cannot
fight the uh satan and things that are
happening the
signs and times are all around and my
question was
how can we kind of stay how can we stay
on
the rock when we are like
used to or in the past been on a
different rock or something you know
spiritually that makes sense yeah i
think so
i feel i feel different sometimes and
i know i know i can't always be
disciplined
to to have the right way to go
and so i i um
i kind of took courage called sorry well
i'm glad you called kind of help
well that we'll we'll see what we can do
josiah
first of all you know once a person
comes to christ
and they give their lives to jesus they
need to believe the bible says
everything in a christian life is based
on faith believe that he loves you
he would not go through all that he went
through to die
if it wasn't entirely possible for you
to be saved
that means trust him also do not be
afraid
of the devil because jesus promises be
of good cheer i've overcome the world
the bible says greater is he that is in
you
than he that is in the world and so and
then over and over
it tells us fear not fear not you know
moses said be courageous to joshua be
courageous be very courageous
if the lord is with you jesus said when
he ascended to heaven i am with you
always even unto the end he will never
leave you or forsake you
and so just have courage that christ is
going to keep his word he's going to be
with you
and through his word jesus
is the word of god jesus is the rock
christ said he that hears these words of
mine is building
on a rock the tenth commandment is
written on a rock
david killed goliath with a rock the
wise man builds his house on the rock
and so by staying rooted in the word
you'll be on the rock so read the word
talk to him every day
and it'll keep you strong friends you
hear the music this is just half time
we've got more questions coming
don't go anywhere
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets political tensions
are at an all-time high
does the bible have anything to say
about the times in which we are living
hi friends this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering
if the world's about to implode some are
fearful that global events point to a
coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at afbookstore.com or by calling
[Music]
a clearer 1-800-538-7275 of god and his
plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends if you've tuned in
somewhere in route this is bible answers
live we are live and if you have a bible
question you're invited to call
800-463-7297
463 7297 and
we are streaming on facebook and
you can simply go to the amazing facts
facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page and
you can join us and take a look at
what's happening here in the little
bitty studio
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross we're going to go to the phone
lines we've got jack listening from
colorado jack welcome to the program
thank you for taking my call absolutely
so one quick thing i've been watching
amazing facts on roku for a while and
the last
sabbath school i'd say about the last
eight to ten they're not loading on my
roku well enough so i don't know if the
technical
uh support or whoever i'm glad you told
us that we will uh we the person who
needs to check on that's probably
helping us engineer right now we'll
we'll look into that make sure it works
yeah
it started about um i haven't been able
to watch any of the new
the new quarterly but it happened about
uh a
quarter of the way through the
witnessing the uh quarterly
all right we'll check the upload make
sure that's working um but
at any rate um i had a question
about and i i'll just be honest i have a
problem with
and struggling with marijuana and i want
to know
where in the bible that talks about
marijuana and
if it does what i can do about it and
how
maybe you can pray for me and just give
me some advice about that all right
absolutely first of all
before we close our call with you we
will pray for you
secondly i've got to preface my
statements by saying
there are you know most of our medicines
come from a variety of herbs
aspirin i think comes from willow bark
and you've got
a variety of medications you know valium
comes from valerian root or it might be
a chemical
extraction of it now or reproduction but
so many of the medicines are connected
with plants over time
and but those things were not ever to
become dependent on any drug
and so if a doctor prescribes a
particular medicine for a limited time
but you don't want to become dependent
on a drug unless you know a doctor may
prescribe something that's necessary
because you have a chronic condition
most people that i know and i grew up
my mother started smoking pot with me at
13 so i've got my black belt and
marijuana and i as a hippie i grew a
little bit
and and but you know and
karen and i live in a in a county that's
called the emerald triangle we've got uh
so some of the biggest pot plantations
in the country
around our property you can see them on
google earth
no they're not ours i promise friends
pastor ross give me a witness if they're
not ours you've been to my place
so i i understand
what the issues are and i've got friends
that started smoking pot they really
just got dependent on it
and you can get addicted to it
it's obviously not god's will for us to
be addicted to a drug like that and
especially on
some recreational use it alters your
mind
it lowers your iq it affects your
witness for christ
now you're looking for some scripture
you know the bible tells us our bodies
are the temple of the holy spirit
and you know you're not going to find
marijuana mentioned in the bible you're
not going to find tobacco
mentioned in the bible but you know if
you look on any cigarette pack it's
going to say this stuff's going to kill
you it's
bad for you and you ask what would jesus
do would jesus
need to smoke pot you know
i don't believe that you'd see jesus
doing that and so
um i think that so much of what's being
said not everything but so much of
what's being said
about marijuana and legalizing marijuana
is not because of the medicinal value
some maybe but a lot of it is also
because people are wanting to just
have accessibility to it for
recreational purposes
otherwise when i fly over mendocino
county and i see pot gardens everywhere
i'm thinking there's a whole lot of sick
people out there
well all that pot they're growing so i
don't know if i'm helping answer your
question jack but
i want to pray with you you still with
us of course
yeah and and like i said i've got some
dear friends that i know they they
started using pot and then they realized
hey this is getting to be expensive as
well as habit forming
and they wanted to have clear heads and
be free of it
and it can be difficult like any habit
or addiction
but let me pray for you okay father in
heaven i just pray
that you'll be with jack and others like
him that might be struggling with
an addiction to something like marijuana
or any drug
that you give them victory and the as
lord you've helped
me with you know problems with alcohol
tobacco and so many things and millions
of others
that you can help him you can set him
free i pray you break the chains
you've said if the son will make you
free you'll be free indeed and do this
for them now lord
we pray in jesus name amen amen
uh jack we do have a book we'll be happy
to send you you'll find it encouraging
it's called
tips for resisting temptation and i
think you'll be
encouraged just asked for the book tips
for resisting temptation it's practical
and of course if we want to live a godly
life we're going to face
temptation and trials but we can have
victory in jesus
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and again ask for the book it's called
tips for resisting temptation and we'll
be happy to send that out to anyone who
calls and asks we've got robert
listening in washington
college place robert welcome to the
program
hey good evening pastors evening thank
you for calling
you're welcome i
was wondering about the keys of the
kingdom i
understand anyway that there's a couple
churches anyway that
have the keys of the kingdom i'm not
sure if they share their keys or
or how that works but um well you know
at least one church
claims that because they've got the keys
they can only they're the only people
that can baptize kind of things so
what are all is involved in having keys
of the kingdom
well good question and that's there let
me read it for you it's in matthew
chapter 16 18.
and i also say to you that you are peter
and on this rock i will build my church
and the gates of hades will not prevail
against it and i'll give you the keys of
the kingdom of heaven and whatever you
bind on earth
will be bound in heaven whatever you
loose on earth will be loosed in heaven
and he commanded his disciples now he's
not just talking to peter
he's talking to the disciples in
particular the apostles that are there
and peter is not the you know first pope
as some will say
what he's simply saying is peter the
statement you've made is the rock on
which we're going to build the church
he said you're peter that word there
peter is petros
and that means a rock you can pick up
and throw it'll roll in the surf it's a
small rock
he said but on this petra the petra
is the statement peter had made that you
are the christ the son of the living god
on this i will build my church and the
gates of hades will not be able to
withstand you
stop you from sharing the gospel and
i'll give you the keys
the keys are in the truth the keys that
unlock
people from sin and that break the
chains
is the word of god and the gospel and as
they share the gospel or
do not share the gospel people are saved
or they remain in bondage and so
he's saying look i'm giving you the
ability to
liberate people through the proclamation
of the gospel and i think
there's a verse where it says that jesus
has the key of the son of david
is that in revelation pastor ross yes to
christ it's given the key
yeah and so in sharing christ jesus is
the one ultimately who has the keys and
i think even
isaiah says he will have the key
and isaiah 22 verse 22 says the key of
the house that david i'll lay upon his
shoulder
and then that is referenced in
revelation 3 verse 7.
yeah so jesus in the gospel is the key
it's not that the disciples are a church
any particular denomination says we've
got the secret keys
hopefully that helps a little robert and
i'm just wondering if um
we don't necessarily have a book that
deals with that we can share but
there's some good studies if you know i
go to any protestant commentary explains
these verses pretty well
appreciate your call we've got uh jim
listening in
crescent city california jim welcome to
the program
hello how are you guys tonight doing
well
thank you for calling yes my pleasure
uh i have we have a
bible study group and we had some
discussion
on the forgiveness of god and we all
agree
that we are forgiven instantaneously
when we repent and we ask for that
but when do we find that our sins
are blotted out cast into the sea
and remembered no more great
great question you know the parable
jesus told
about the unmerciful debtor it's in
matthew 18.
in that parable jesus says that there's
this
servant and he wastes a lot of the
king's money
and the king says he's going to be sold
and his wife and everything and
he falls down and he begs the king he
says the lord have patience and i'll pay
thee
all and the king is moved with the
compassion and he forgives them this
hundred thousand talent or ten thousand
talent debt
and so that man is forgiven and he
should walk out of the king's presence
just so excited because the king said
i'm going to forgive you
and he frees him he's freed at that
moment when the king says i forgive you
but he goes out then and he finds a
fellow servant
that owes him forty dollars by
comparison
takes him by the throat and throws him
in prison for this meager amount
well eventually word gets back to the
king how he treated his fellow servant
and the king says look i've had a report
that you did not pass on my forgiveness
you did not live out my mercy or
practice what i did for you
and so you're losing your forgiveness
i'm revoking it
because in looking at your works you are
not worthy of it
so in salvation anybody can come to
christ and be justified by faith we
receive incredible mercy
but the bible says we need to then have
new hearts
and by grace want to live a new life
even in the lord's prayer
it says forgive us our debts as we
forgive others
in the judgment at the end of time if
it's found that we were only christians
in word
well our forgiveness is revoked you know
if we're only saying lord lord jesus
said there'll be many that say lord lord
and he'll say i don't know you
and so if we're sincere and we come to
him and we are receiving the new heart
then we will show love for others that's
the great commandment love the lord
love your neighbor so when do we receive
forgiveness instantaneously
when is the record finally purged and
that's at the great judgment and that
takes place
at the end of time exactly
and so when christ in the most holy
place stands up
when michael stands up and leaves
and it's finished the judgment is
then permanent those that remain
the guilty yeah yeah that's revelation
yeah and so that's when we have
permanent blotting out and forget
thing or the the books are
then emptied of those sins yes you're
found to be righteous yeah at the end of
time
when uh it says that the temple there
was smoke in the temple and no man can
enter
anymore once it says no man can enter
the temple it means this forgiveness is
over and the devil can't take them
anymore in other words they are sealed
and saved
the saved or saved the lost or lost
that's that's where probation closes now
some people are surprised to learn that
probation closes before the
end shortly before the end it's like the
story of noah
where before the rain came noah and his
family went into the ark and the door
was shut
and life continued to go on outside the
ark for seven days
and at the end of seven days uh the rain
came
but the saved were saved inside the ark
the lost were shut out
and there was no more hope for them
there'll be a short time when the seven
last plagues fall
when the lost are lost and saved or
sealed
everyone will have either the mark of
the beast or the seal of god
and i think the verse referring to that
passage revelation 22 11 it says
he who is unjust let him be unjust still
he who is filthy let him be filthy still
he who is righteous let him be righteous
still he who is holy
let him be holy still and then verse 12
and behold i'm coming quickly
so that declaration the close probation
occurs just before
jesus comes thank you for your call jim
uh
next caller that we have is gracilda
listening in
california griselda welcome to the
program hello
hi hi good evening evening it was a
beautiful day
in um california amen we could see the
blue sky and wondered what it was
yes well pastors i have to say i've been
going through a lot
and um i've been praying a lot and i
want it in my
prayers i always want to be led by the
holy spirit
and know that what i'm praying for is
something that also aligns with god's
will
that i'm praying according to his will
so with that i had questions about
if there is more than one holy spirit
or holy spirit because obviously i
i want to be led by the holy spirit to
know that um
i'm praying for you know what is god's
will for my future for my family
and um so i needed a little bit
clarification on that when i was reading
revelation and hopefully maybe you can
kind of talk and give me some
a little bit explanation on that sure
now pastor ross probably has the verse
there in revelation where it talks about
the seven spirits
yeah revelation 5 6 yeah
yes 5 6 where yes where it's um
the seven spirits of god let me tell you
what that means
grace if if you look in isaiah 11
you'll see that isaiah talks about seven
characteristics or
facets of god the spirit now there is
one holy spirit
i think in ephesians paul says there's
one lord one faith one baptism
and one spirit and to which we're
baptized
and it tells us what those facets of the
spirit are
and in isaiah 11 it says it says the
spirit of the lord will rest upon him
that being one
the spirit of wisdom to understanding
three counsel
for might five knowledge six fear the
lord
seven so here in other places it talks
about different
facets or characteristics of the spirit
and it doesn't mean there's only seven
because you know you talk about the
fruits of the spirit
that you read about in galatians chapter
five
and i forget what the number is but it's
probably more than seven there
and you get these different facets or
fruits of the spirit so when you're
praying there's one god
one father one son one spirit but there
are several different characteristics of
the holy spirit
just like jesus is i was
just preaching this week there's seven
times jesus said i
am it says i'm the door on the wetter
water
i'm the bread i'm the gate i'm the vine
so jesus looks at the different facets
or allegories of his character
and in the same way the holy spirit
they're different facets
you know we do have a book that uh we'll
be happy to sing to you um
griselda it is called life in the spirit
it talks about the holy spirit the need
for the holy spirit
and how we can experience the holy
spirit you know this is a gift that god
wants to give us and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks just ask for the book
it's called life in the spirit
and the number is 800 835 6747
and again ask for the book it's called
life in the spirit
thank you for your call we got time for
one more yeah we got a couple more yeah
we've got james listening in
minnesota james welcome to the program
hi pastors
how are you doing well thank you for
calling
so i just wanted to start off by saying
in 1994 i had this miraculous experience
i was
standing on stage and playing in front
of thousands of people and
i felt naked in front of the audience
and i could sense god
calling me and i went home and i fasted
and prayed
for seven days and i came to matthew 24
verse or sorry matthew 12 verse 8
and when i read the son of man is lord
of the sabbath
that those words were like
ensconced with light and it
led me directly to the sabbath so
and immediately after that i found
amazing facts and i just gotta say every
time
i have one of those holy spirit moments
where
i felt led to a conclusion
i would listen 20 year sermons and
you would hit that exact same topic and
have the exact same conclusion on like
99 percent of the time so
well praise well that's a that's a god
thing
glory to god that's exactly what i
believe so um
in that time period of um the last 26
years
uh the subject of you know how matthew
um 24 and luke 17
um about the mingling of the destruction
of jerusalem and
the end of the world right they're
they're synonymous they
they follow the same sermon from jesus
and um towards the end of luke
and matthew um where it talks about two
men shall
be in the field one shall be taken the
other left
i've heard you in many sermons
and on this program say that the one
that
shall be taken is
referring to like the death of the
wicked at
the second coming of jesus but i wanted
to share with you that i found in
special testimonies for ministers and
workers that it says
the one that shall be taken his name
shall
stand in the book of life while those
who are left are the ones who suffer
eternal separation from god
so having heard that
aspect is it possible that this is a
direct
reference to
the mark of the beast because i've
done some research into the wording of
that text
and many protestant expositors
said that the the word that is
taken is in reference to
as a prisoner like yeah let me
we've got to get to a question pretty
quick um
we're going to run out of time so you're
wondering
it what does it what is it is it taken
or is it left
the one taken is it saved is the one
left the one that is saved
is that kind of the crux of the question
yeah well could it be referring to the
the mark of the beast because
the testimonies say that it's the one
that is taken his name shall stand in
the book of light
all right well let's talk about that
real quick um
you've got two different passages and
actually
luke adds something you've got luke 17
and you've also got in matthew 24 verse
40.
in one passage it's they ask him lord
where
is he taken at that maybe in luke 17
verse 40.
and he says wherever the body is there
the eagles will be gathered
you know it's entirely possible that
[Music]
what the um gospel writers are talking
about here is a separation
two women doing the same thing two men
sleeping in a bed two men working in a
field
one is separated from the other one is
saved one is not who is taken and who is
left
can be actually different references in
the gospel it's basically saying
one is saved one is lost they are
outwardly doing the same thing
and i've just met christian scholars
that say both views can be argued from
the bible
um because yeah one place the word taken
means like receive to yourself
another place that talks about taken
away like when the flood came and took
them all away
and it's talking about being taken away
in judgment
the real key is outwardly they're doing
the same thing
sleeping in the bed is a symbol for
death two kinds of people that are dead
now the saved and the lost that's
it dead and christ will rise and the
other group is left behind
then you've got two kinds of people that
are working in the field
true gospel false gospel one is saved
one is not
two kinds of churches women grinding at
the grain working with the word the true
and the false
two women in revelation so jesus is
saying there's two roads and i think we
we sometimes it's like a revolving door
we're wondering well which side of the
door is it
i think the point he's making is that
there's going to be a separation of the
two
you know it's also interesting past
today it's word a little different
in matthew 24 and then in luke
um in matthew 24 talks about two men in
the field the one stake and the others
left luke talks about two men
asleep the ones taking the others left
so
it could quite possibly be like many of
the parables that jesus told
he told it more than once and disciples
recorded it differently
different aspects were being emphasized
with the different parallels
exactly what i'm saying in the different
gospels exactly
yeah it could be he could be referring
to the different group but it's just
saying that they're separated one is
saved one is lost
and it's kind of like saying well did
you go out the right way or did you go
out the left way
you're going opposite ways thank you
appreciate that james hope it made some
sense
thanks for your call we've got uh time
maybe for one more kate is listening in
brooklyn new york hey welcome to the
program
we got about a minute kate
good evening pastor dark and uh pastor
ross
so in luke 7 verse 19 uh
why did john the baptist ask jesus
if he was a messiah since
when he was baptized the jesus
the god himself spoke and said this is
my
beloved son and what can be more
important than god himself saying that
this is my son right he questioned well
it's a good question it's because john
the baptist was in jail he had been
there for a while it says while he was
in prison
herod would sometimes sin for him and
talk to him so he spent quite a while in
a dungeon
and he kept waiting for jesus to
announce himself as messiah and
even john the baptist thought well the
son of god is going to sit on the throne
of david and
and he's going to you know lead our
armies in battle against the romans and
john wasn't even totally clear on how
that prophecy was going to be fulfilled
and so as time went by and nothing
happened he thought well maybe he began
the devil was assailing john with doubts
and he sent disciples saying are you the
one we look for or do we wait for
another
and john you know jesus sent back word
to encourage him that he was not wrong
when he declared him to be the messiah
the lamb of god
so um yeah he just needed some
encouragement i think john was getting
discouraged as he waited in jail
and the devil was attacking him with
second thoughts and jesus sent him a
word of encouragement and then said john
was the greatest
of the prophets thank you kate good
question
hey listening friends before we sign off
we want to remind you
we have a big program coming called
revelation now write that down somewhere
revelation now dot com and you're going
to be seeing we'll be doing a global
prophecy study broadcast
beginning october 23rd going through
november 14
and you can join in your home in your
church invite your friends over
and pray for the program and spread the
word
in the meantime thank you for keeping us
on the air you can just go to amazing
facts
donate help us keep saving people see
you next time
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets political tensions
are at an all-time high
does the bible have anything to say
about the times in which we are living
hi friends this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering if the world's
about to implode
some are fearful that global events
point to a coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it at 1-800
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at af afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747 or visit our
website at
[Music]
amazingfacts.org